il boxait à domicile a remporté son
combat le super-plume muriautin khalil
el hadri s'est imposé aux points face au
mexicain cristian lopez flores sa
troisième victoire consécutive depuis le
mois de mars 2021 si tout le monde les
gens sont
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
au programme de ce gala de boxe cinq
combats avec plusieurs ceintures wba en
jeu pour le plus grand plaisir du public
pour les gens qui sont pas trop du monde
de la boxe est plutôt un bon moyen de
venir regarder apprécié et surtout de
passer un bon moment en famille quoi je
sais que c'est des gros combats qui sont
attendus ce soir et que ça va être une
vraie une belle soirée
le club de boxe des murs obame
l'héritage organise régulièrement des
soirées de gala la dernière en date le
19 décembre 2020
l'occasion de confirmer que la ville est
un territoire de boxe on n'était pas
longtemps dans une salle qui était plein
et c'est bien celle bien sûr bien sûr
jean vianney c'est une bonne chose
depuis tout le temps je pense que les
mureaux c'est une vraie tête de boxe n'y
a pas que les mureaux il ya le
département des yvelines
les mureaux en fait partie c'est la
locomotive et on veut continuer dans
cette voie mais ce qu'il faut c'est
continuer dans la voie de la difficulté
est aujourd'hui c'est l'organisation
continue à trouver des partenaires qui
nous accompagnent qui nous font
confiance pour pouvoir faire de belles
soirées comme comme celle ci est un
nouveau rendez vous est déjà pris pour
accueillir encore plus de monde un
nouveau gala de boxe devrait être
organisé en avril 2022